hi I am Danai gurira and I play Ocoee
in the MCU and today on BuzzFeed I will
take quiz to find out which Avenger I am
what would you risk your life for hope
peace family purpose redemption honor
freedom justice duty there are many
things I think are very valid I would go
with freedom choose an Avenger to bring
home to Captain Marvel Hulk Iron Man
Captain America at man
okuu a Thor Black Widow or nebula I
would go with Captain Marvel I think
she'd get along the best with you know
with parents and be the most lovely
couch my own character and that I think
I think that's Captain Marvel you have
the chance to wield one Infinity stone
which would you choose the Power Stone
the soul stone the reality stone the
mind stone the time stone a space a good
time what would you say your biggest
weakness is I tend to live in the past I
constantly bite off more than I can chew
I'm flaky I'm insecure I don't look
before I leave I tend to be stubborn
headed I'll I like a lot no I seldom pay
attention to what's going on around me
no sometimes I can be narrow-minded I
never take time for myself I tend to
overreact
no no he's are hard what if you don't
have any of these reasons all right fine
I constantly fight off more than I can
chew what do you think your most useful
asset would be if you join The Avengers
your strategy your bravery your strength
your ingenuity your persistence your
charisma your morale your intelligence
your ambition your leadership your
honesty your selflessness I would go
with persistence which non Avenger would
you want on your team against Thanos
hello sir to the collector Tallis
doorman ooh or the Grandmaster Oh see on
your team on your team all right then if
it's on my team then I'll go hello
finally if you were alone at the
supermarket during the snap who is the
first person you would check on to see
if they survived your parents your
siblings your co-workers your
significant other your kids your
favorite celebrity someone else I'm not
listed your best friend your pets I
think I would definitely check out my
parents I've met you la while compassion
isn't your strong suit your fiercely
loyal and prideful you'll do anything to
make sure you gain the recognition and
respect
but I love you nebula love you girl well
then I'd have to pick myself if I have
to pay you know me I'd have to I mean
not myself she's not myself I would have
to pick okay
she's gonna be
[Music]